We sat in comfortable chairs.
They were designed by the time traveler, as we shall call him.
"Listen carefully to what I say," he said.
"I shall make statements with which you will not agree."
"Why will we not agree?" I asked.
"Because the science and mathematics you know are not correct," he said.
"You believe there are only three dimensions: length, breadth, and thickness."
"There is nothing to argue with that," the youngest member of our little group said.
"Exactly!" The time traveler answered.
"But there is also a fourth dimension: time."
"We all know about time," another member of the group said.
"Time passes."
"I do not agree," the time traveler said.
"Length, breadth, and thickness do not pass."
"They stay in the same place in space."
"We move about them."
"I can prove that time is the same."
"It does not pass."
"We move in time the same way that we move in breadth, length, and thickness."
The time traveler smiled.
"It is clear," he said,...
..."that there is only one way I can convince you that I am right."
"We must conduct an experiment."
He left the room and we heard him walking toward his laboratory.
He soon returned.
He was carrying what looked like a clock.
"This is a model of a time machine," he said.
"I plan to build such a machine."
We followed him to his laboratory.
There, we saw the actual machine;...
...not quite complete but large enough for a man to sit in.